[Music]
so when I want to think about the job of
being a salesperson and there's so much
great work out there you know Dan Pink's
book to sell as human great great piece
that really speaks to the fact that
we're all salespeople whether we're
teachers that were actually salespeople
for a living or were we're business
leaders or community leaders we're
selling we're selling ideas we're trying
to motivate others to take action we're
all salespeople as Dan would argue and I
think he's right and one of the things
we've seen from great salespeople is
that they are able to take rejection and
kind of roll with the punches right they
don't take it personally and that is
that is a unique attribute of
salespeople but it is something that can
be learned and and one of the things in
it's hard right it's hard to to come
into a sales job where you are going to
experience a lot of rejection a lot more
rejection than acceptance right if you
just look at it statistically a great
salesperson is not going to convert at a
hundred percent they're going to convert
well south of that which means seventy
to ninety percent of the time they're
hearing no they're hearing no I don't
want to spend time with you no I don't
want to buy what you're selling I know
we like your competitors instead we're
doing business with them you know one of
the things I always tell salespeople to
try to it's it's important to not say
turn a deaf ear or ignore that no
because it's important to understand why
right if we think about I know I don't
want to spend time with you or no I
don't buy what you're saying is it that
the insight we're trying to use to
capture that customers attention or the
story we're trying to tell them the
sales meeting needs work maybe the the
inside itself is not resonating maybe
we're not doing a great job telling that
story or customizing to that it's that
customer so it's important that you
actually hear know and that you learn
from it but it's also important that you
don't take it personally because
oftentimes customers I know for lots of
reasons I say no we don't have a budget
no we don't see any value no we're an
execution mode we're not we're not going
to move forward and it's important that
we don't see that as a reflection on us
personally but it's also important that
we see it as a reflection of the fact
that maybe the thing we're teaching them
the insight will bring the table isn't
that compelling or provocative it's not
worth their time maybe it's a reflection
of the fact that we haven't
really learn to tell that story in a
compelling way and there's things we can
do maybe with our manager or things we
can practice in a safe place back in the
home office to get ready for the next
sales conversation that we can really
make that story resonate in a powerful
way for the customer maybe they're
saying no because what we're trying to
sell ultimately is not that unique or
valuable or credible to the client and
that's insight we've got to take back to
the organization it it's important
therefore to kind of really
differentiate what's personal and
distinguish that from what's
professional and what's about the
company right it's great to hear no so
we understand how to get better
it's great to hear no so that we
understand what feedback we can take
back to our organization whether that's
marketing hey we need help really
sharpening this insight or its product
gosh our competitors are kicking our
butts out in the marketplace because
their product does X Y & Z and ours
doesn't and we really need to add this
functionality if we want to be
competitive the no I find is almost
never personal for a salesperson it's
typically a reflection of a lack of
insight a lack of compelling delivery of
that insight or a lack of product or
service capability right it's not about
you as a person it's typically about
about what you're there to say or how
you're saying it while you're there to
sell or how you're selling it in the
eyes of the customer but you're going to
hear know a lot as a salesperson and
you're not going to get very far in
sales unless you get comfortable with
that and really separate it out from the
again the personal versus the
professional know if you will and learn
from those knows to get better over time
so when I think about this idea of how
and what and what can we learn from
salespeople the best salespeople we look
at and they get told no 90 percent of
the time and how they're able to
separate that from again the
professional versus the personal I'm not
taking this personally but it doesn't
mean I'm not learning from it doesn't
mean I'm not sharpening my message
doesn't mean I'm not sharpening my
technique and it doesn't mean I'm not
going to take those insights those
rejections back to the home office and
try to pattern recognize what are we
hearing from customers why are they
saying no that we as a company can learn
from now what does that mean for the
rest of us right as we we talked about
before we're all in the job of selling
at some level and I think that when we
hear no when we see an audience when we
see
other people reject our message they'll
say I'm a teacher and I'm trying to
compel a group of students to to embrace
a topic or to pursue a project with
passion and with excitement and it's
just not working there they're saying no
they're rejecting my message there's a
lot of stuff we can learn about that is
it what we're saying is that how we're
saying it how do I break through that to
that individual how do I customize my
message how do I sharpen that that
teaching or that insight how do I make
the thing that I'm ultimately trying to
get them to do or to buy more compelling
or there's a lot we can learn about this
how do we pitch things how do i pitch my
boss on giving me a raise how do I get
my students to actually do the work that
that I need them to do they need them to
get excited about how I get my kids to
take out the garbage that might be a
there might be a tough one but we're all
selling right and there's a lot we can
learn from when the customer says no you
know one things we or the recipient says
no the the counterparty one of things we
always say in in sales you know
customers will will often say they'll
use budget as an excuse they'll say no I
don't have the budget to buy your
solution or your product and salespeople
hear this all the time what one of the
best salespeople I ever worked with true
insight seller told me is budget is
never the reason it is never the reason
if your insight is sharp enough it's as
if it's delivered in a compelling enough
way and if what you're selling really
does address an unseen opportunity that
is going to change the way the client
does business they'll find the budget
for it even if there's no budget
allocated so when the customer tells you
no because it's budget they're throwing
up a smoke screen you got to push harder
and you got to ask the really hard
questions to really dig deep because
ultimately it probably does come back to
what you're saying how you're saying it
what your ultimate ly trying to get them
to do and that's true as well right when
we're communicating messages to others
to our boss to our students to our kids
when we think about their their
smokescreen answers their generic
answers I'm too busy I'm not interested
cetera let's ask ourselves those
questions let's be introspective and
understand you know is that what we're
trying to get them to do and I haven't
really sharpened the edge of that why
it's worth doing or is it the way I'm
delivering it and what can I learn from
that rejection to sharpen the way I tell
that story the sharpen the way I essage
that to the other side moving forward
[Music]
you